well one month from today thousands of
clark county students will be back in
the classroom for the first time
in almost a year and we will get a first
look at what that hybrid instruction
might look like
a little later today our bianca holman
reports how one local charter school
is getting ready for students this
morning
the centennial hills campus here on the
northwest side of town
is going to be welcoming students k
through fifth grade
but they of course will be on a hybrid
model
this in-person learning at least gives
us that opportunity to target
you know those areas that the students
need most
to give them that opportunity to grow
socially and emotionally and also to
increase that socialization
and most importantly the hands-on
approach to education
safety remains a top priority for school
leaders students will wear a mask
social distancing will be in place and
students will not eat lunch on campus
reporting from the northwest side of the
valley bianca holman 8 news now